we have a volunteer military in the
United States that in many senses is a
good thing most people don't want to be
in the military and having enough people
volunteering prevents the United States
from having a draft and conscripted
people to military service now that
being said the size of the military that
the government thinks we need is
insanely overblown it's caused by the
number of bases we have around the world
and a whole host of other foreign policy
reasons but let's put that aside for now
we have a volunteer military and I
prefer that to having a draft and the
military has screening guidelines one of
the problems that we've been talking
about for the last many years is
extremism in the military we've talked
about it in the Air Force years ago
we've talked about it more recently
across all branches and more recently
we've even been drilling down into white
nationalism in the military we did a
story a little while ago about eleven
military members who were members of
this group called identity Europa which
is a white nationalist group that's one
example we as in most normal people
don't want white nationalists in the
military we don't want them in our
police departments either we've talked
about that that's a story for another
day
so the NDAA the National Defense
Authorization Act had a measure in it in
the house to screen for white
nationalist beliefs to keep them out of
the military that's a good provision
that provision was quietly removed last
week with no fanfare by the
republican-controlled Senate because the
provision for screening out white
nationalists was in the version sent to
the Senate by the house no longer in the
version that the Senate marked up the
revised Senate version no longer has a
provision in it to screen for white
nationalism instead it just says the
military has to screen for extremists
and gang-related activity white
nationalism is a major problem it was
included in the document someone had to
go in and remove it and indeed it is now
gone the Senate version with white
nationalism removed has been sent to
Donald Trump for signature now you might
say sort of seems like a small tweak who
really cares well why did
Senate go out of its way to remove that
provision they were given the House
version and they said let's take out the
part about screening for white
nationalism who changed the language as
of yet it's unclear huffington post
contacted US Senate Armed Services
Committee Chairman Jim Inhofe a
Republican from Oklahoma didn't respond
as of this filming to the huffington
post's requests for why that language
was removed and this is a problem that
is growing they have infected the
military the Senate has removed what is
quite frankly not even a really
significant provision meant to keep them
out it just says let's screen for white
nationalism why did they do it who are
they appeasing why won't they explain
who did it or why it was done as of just
a few hours ago Donald Trump remember
announced on Twitter that trans people
will be found and kicked out of the
military but milquetoast language to
screen out white nationalism has been
removed very often when the left talks
about the rise of white nationalism in
the United States the rise of
anti-semitism I see a lot of comments
that say this is totally overblown this
isn't really an issue very often those
are tacit defenses of Donald Trump
because to concede that there's a rise
implicitly points the finger at Donald
Trump but this is a very real and
present thing in the United States under
Trump and as I've said before I'm not
saying Trump created racists
I'm not saying Trump created new white
nationalists what is undeniable is that
Donald Trump has emboldened and
coalesced extremism even people like
Richard Spencer a white nationalist told
me that this is what Donald Trump has
done and even just what is again it's a
pretty flaccid measure just let's screen
for white nationalism
why would it be removed by the Senate
very very strange and hopefully at some
point we will get an answer to that I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learn
but are busy blinka stakes the best and
most popular non-fiction books and
condenses them into 15-minute audiobooks
I'm sure that if you're like me you have
a very long list of books that you've
been meaning to read you only have so
many hours in the day and that's why
blink astiz so amazing they take the
most important information the themes
the insights from each book and they
distill it into a 15 minute audio book
that you can listen to in one sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on
blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
NK is t.com /pa ke ma n